the accused Golden State Killer is
expected to be back in a California
Court next month
prosecutors say Joseph D'Angelo is the
man who raped and murdered people in
this 1970s and 80s you made this first
court appearance Friday
investigators used DNA testing and
websites to track him down but as The
Associated Press reports at first that
led to the wrong man John Blackstone now
on the questions being raised about this
investigative tool handcuffed to a
wheelchair Joseph D'Angelo was arraigned
on charges for two murders in 1978 he
was barely audible answering the judge
investigators found D'Angelo using DNA
from crime scenes decades ago which they
submitted to a publicly shared genealogy
website called jed match cold-case
investigator paul holes we were able to
do this without seeking the legal
authority in terms of getting the
federal grand jury subpoena or the
search warrant that we would need if we
wanted to search the other types of
genealogy sites jed match users submit
DNA profiles they buy from sites like
ancestry.com and 23andme
they plug their data for free into JED
match searching for distant relatives
within days investigators found distant
cousins of the suspected Golden State
killer we literally went back to the
great-great-great-grandfather with
individuals that were born in the the
early part of the 1800s it took four
months to identify D'Angelo as a likely
suspect but to prove it
investigators followed him to collect
his DNA from something he threw away
district attorney and Murray Schubert it
could be he left a tissue it could be
that he you know put his hands on a door
handle but it was what I call abandoned
DNA that abandoned DNA solved a 44 year
old mystery and four months but also
raises concerns about the privacy of DNA
collection isn't it almost certain that
a defense attorney is going to call this
an illegal search we would expect that
we anticipate it we're fully prepared to
deal with that through the court
processes jed matt says law enforcement
never approached them in a statement jed
match tells users if you are concerned
about non genial
logical uses of your DNA you should not
upload your DNA to the database for CBS
this morning Saturday John Blackstone
Sacramento I think a lot of people are
okay with us finding criminals using the
technology but when you think about the
numbers of people with their information
out there well that's all it res John
points out it raises a whole new
question about privacy but it is a
fascinating development in
crime-fighting affairs fascinating what
they did really is